hey man it's me kevin smith and welcome
to masters of the universe
revelation celebration a celebration
of the writers of masters of the
universe of revelation very masturbatory
on my behalf because i was one of the
writers but
it's more a chance for me to focus a a
spotlight shine a spotlight
on the many talents that brought
revelation to life and sitting right
next to me
is the man behind episode three the man
behind
fat man beyond the man behind what else
uh i don't know splinter
splinter that's right it's short that
he's gonna be shooting that
how much did you raise yeah 230 thousand
dollars from kickstarter uh the man
behind what was the
what was the tv show where you get like
the jj abrams [ __ ] oh castle rock
treadstone carnival row star trek picard
the continental look at him just pulling
out his
tv dick and showing you how [ __ ] full
of girth it is
uh mark is a professional tv writer
something he aspired or
professional writer we should just say
um rather than just tv
but he is something he aspired to do
originally for those of you who don't
know we do a podcast every week called
fat man beyond um so for those
unfamiliar with that podcast who are
only here because of revelation
um mark stands next to me every week
and usually improves every movie that we
talk about
he's got great writers chops and he also
has these billion dollar ideas that he
just spits out and
where you're like don't tell people that
man he just gave away star wars damn it
so when uh i got a job doing this
masters universe thing naturally i was
like i'm [ __ ] pulling this
guy in so he's got you know the the
chops he's got a long list of credits
uh he's got the drive the talent he got
himself here he manifested
his career he was originally [ __ ] a
news hound right he's a journalist
which you know there's no future in
journalism
we just lost our journalist kids who
were just like i'm about to write an
article
not anymore yeah freshman in columbia
journalism school oh
no look there'll always be a need for
journalist kids but
he didn't have a need to be a journalist
anymore he wanted to do something else
how long you wanted to be a writer
uh since i was 13 years old what what
did what'd you say that said
ah uh the the first thing that i saw
that told me that writer was a thing a
person does was flash gordon
the 1980 film so who read that um
lorenzo
something or other and it made you go
like it made me because i was sitting
there like petrified that flash gordon
was going to get killed
um he used to get his hand into the to
the stump and arboria and i'm like
you know 11 years old like losing my
mind that they're going to kill flash
gordon
and at that point you don't know they
stole it from dune yes
my dad leans over and it's like it's
okay they never kill the hero i'm like
who's this they
there's a vey i just thought these
things manifested magically onto the
screen that they were happening
no there was just happening this is a
documentary right clearly and so the
they
began me sort of investigating like who
makes these things and why does some of
these people who make the thing make
more things that i like who's this
spielberg guy who's this lucas guy
and why are they all white you know what
they need
they need a plucky side because his dad
was like and when i say they
you know what i mean yeah so he
introduced you to the idea of like
authorship this yeah there's somebody
like
were you a religious kid no not really
so then you never had the notion like as
a kid
you're always drilled well in catholic
school it's a terrible thing to say but
they always drill your head
with like matthew mark luke and john
they wrote the gospels you're introduced
to the notion
of writers like from an early age but
those writers were more documentarians
right um it wasn't until like when i was
a kid
we referred to things on tv as it either
looks like the news
which meant real or it looks like the 6
million
man which meant filmed entertainment
so yeah there was it's weird what a
weird notion that like you do get
my sister is the one that taught me
about writing she i found a thing that
she was writing she's like i'm writing a
story about me and my friends i was like
what she's like i'm writing a book it's
like you can't write a book you gotta
ask the government for commission
she was like why do you say that i was
like because the library cards it has
the
the flag on it it's all government they
they're tracking you yeah yeah
i was such a young age i was already
suspected of the government
man but my sister was like anybody could
write you don't need no permission you
just want to write right it's free
it's very ratatouille yeah it's true
anyone could cook
so what's the so at that age then do you
start
like clocking the writers more and more
they become like kind of sexy to you
you know like none of them are sexy
because they're writers
but you begin to you're sitting next to
a writer man neither of us are sad
i would have called you sexy for the
video mark
you're right it's not the sex it's not
the sexy but it's
between like tv and stuff and then you
start to see like steven j canel's name
like donald belisarius and
and and and even comic books you begin
like oh hey there's that guy who writes
that stuff that i like
i keep seeing his name i keep seeing his
name and so the idea of authoring
anything
i think started to seep in there and
then i couldn't draw if i could have
drawn
then i would have been you know frank
miller can't draw
so then it's like you still kind of want
to be frank miller but frank miller who
writes for other people
yeah and i wanted to be a comic book
author first because that seemed
achievable i don't know why would seem
achievable but tough i never thought
about
i went into film instead of comic books
because i was like
you got to be british to make an
announcement you know because there's
neil gaiman
it was uh alan moore or it was grant
morrison
so i was like man you got to be from
overseas like we you couldn't have it
i mean you've seen the accent yeah maybe
jersey good jersey this is
the accent could have leaned heavily
into it i mean that's all they got over
at marvel back in the day all new york
and jersey accents
so yeah man a couple of kids who early
on
hip to the idea of like writers writing
things get written maybe i could be the
person who writes a thing
boom and uh took uh it took a lifetime
and we got there
we got them some of this is faster than
others but still the um
let me ask you this yeah any familiarity
how much familiarity
with uh masters of the universe before
you
jumped into the show um i had some and
not passing familiarity like i had
some of the action figures when i was a
kid i i did the thing where you pull off
humans legs and you put them on skeletor
and you say look at him he's got no
pants on
this is cool right that's why i hired
him i was like he does that pants thing
he got no fans because he was still
doing it in adulthood
um but like so i knew who it was and i
watched the cartoon it wasn't
my thing in as much as like i tried to
explain to the folks on the internet
like
you got to understand in the 80s like
you you have to define what is a fan
right
so some people like fan like oh i love
it but like
i'm like have you seen every episode of
he-man in the master's universe
filmation ever made and they're like not
every episode is like but i have
like and not for the job i watched it in
real time
and mostly because it was on tv
and back then we didn't have the
internet we didn't have
cable when this [ __ ] dropped so we
didn't have options
so they made a thing you watched a
[ __ ] thing i come home from school i
watched it
and you know i would like hate watching
sometimes because i was 13. i was like
this is for babies but i watched it
every episode what else am i going to
watch and i knew the mythology that was
the weirder thing like i didn't
get to collect the toys but i still knew
since i watched every episode
like i knew all the characters all their
relationships blah blah blah
so you know it's going into it
there was familiarity with he-man
but not what like i would construe as
fandom right yeah i mean i was a star
wars fan
like a deep star wars fan i was a star
trek fan i was a deep star trek fan
nerd but there also was not that much of
it to have to keep up with it's true
you know like i i didn't i beyond
splinter of the mind's eye
didn't go deep into the the extended
star wars lore
whereas i didn't watch 210 episodes of
filmation's he-man
you know you know with power to it you
got the gig
eventually i did it i remember my mother
literally saying to me like
all you do is watch cartoons after
school why don't you do something
productive
and you know i was never smart enough to
be like one day
all this information will be useful and
for years it's been useful just in pop
culture referential
stuff but then one day when somebody
came calling said you got an idea for a
massive universe
story i was like you know as a matter of
fact i do and and some of those ideas
ideas exist from when i was a kid in
episode one
he's he-man with the sword of power and
then he says the magic words
again and he gets hit again something i
always wanted them to do
like when i was a kid man so that's a
childish idea
but you know totally at play in what
you're doing because we're writing
make-believe
yes and we can make up the rules as we
go so
episode three um mark gets to handle
in the sounds way sexier than i meant to
uh
the most dangerous man in eternia yes
duncan himself
uh man at arms not duncan idaho who
every now and again i would give duncan
a last name
because duncan idaho from dune is one of
my favorite characters
that's true they got they everyone
steals some dude
right flash gordon movie stole from dude
these guys
star wars stole from dune somewhere
frank herbert like
how about a little yeah a little
something for the ever let me wet my
beak a little
we skim the top of this yogurt and bring
something home for me do you think he
got rich off of the dune books
yeah i mean they're still best sellers i
mean there's 50 million copies in
circulation
so it seems like he might have left
money on the table you know i think they
did
in this day and age like his people be
like you should give a taste of that
that sounds like an acknowledgement to
the works of frank herbert exactly
anything that took place on a beach i'd
be like you should get a piece of that
yeah i don't know i've never seen santa
nothing until dude that kid's playing in
a sandbox give me some of that money
and that's why we got hired to do
masters of the universe ladies and
gentlemen
uh revelation celebration begins ladies
and gentlemen line up your episodes
uh on netflix only on netflix uh this is
episode three
pressing play in three two one pressing
so yes artwork pulled from the mattel
uh library ancient mattel library of
artwork but the
the the opening title sequence from
episode one
that was also missing from the top of
episode two as you see is missing from
here that's predicated on
you know people like skip like i
watching the credits
um even though it'd be tough not to
watch those [ __ ] credits because liam
cunningham's voice is so dope
uh i was looking at the script before i
my original script when i
when i turned it into you uh the title
then was your name's about to happen
it's about to happen julie rogers give
it to me give it to me give it to me
yeah right on merman
uh the original title was way of water
yes great title
it was a good title but it was referring
very explicitly to an entire opening
sequence
that changed drastically let's talk
about that now this was the original
opening sequence
in the script um the idea when we were
uh in the writers room was
we're gonna give people he-man action
every episode
even if our main character is seemingly
gone so
you know our flashbacks allow us to do
everyone's favorite version of he-man in
the massive universe from from the 80s
and stuff like that
so this episode always opened with the
flashback always open on the [ __ ]
pirate ship yeah the crystal z
and the crystal c um because the crystal
c will come into play later in the
episode and whatnot
um and the the line that like was in the
very first draft and made it all the way
through the end
which i still love to this day this is
about to happen once they get
up on right before they get on deck
skeletor has like a brief aside
where he's you know just like what if we
painted the ship a nice granite
and then the action begins again that's
totally [ __ ] mark
the first time i saw this episode i just
laughed and
laughed and laughed like mark apple just
said
the dumbest line and it made it through
87 drafts of a script and recordings and
animations
and still stand up as was this line too
you're all wet
[Laughter]
um so so the uh the
all the episodes open where the idea was
to at least play
a flashback so in episode two the
flashback happens like a little deeper
midway through the episode and then
episode three we started
with it and it always made me go like oh
my god we should do a version of the
show that's just like that
sunny innocent version because you can
see the difference between like how the
boys
light those scenes and animate those
scenes boys being pat and adam the
directors versus like you know the
flashbacks versus the
presents the real world a lot more grim
all right so you read so
that script was this episode was always
meant to be dunkin heavy yes
and when we did the writer's room you
tell them
what was your what was the original
story that you were that you
came up with and were given because in a
writer's room everybody like there was
an outline that i came up with and then
everyone like puts more meat on it like
what about this what if we did this
and the episodes get bigger and thicker
and stuff like that
yeah so it was supposed to be the
opening flashback and then we kind of
spin into the idea where evelyn is
explaining to tila
and andra why she was always more
concerned about duncan than she was
about he-man
yes the idea that like you know he-man's
got the sword and he's got the big smile
and he's got no shirt on
but we were and skeletor was always
fixated on he-man but i knew that that
duncan was the most dangerous man in
eternia and i kind of loved that idea i
think for for me it came out of
a little bit of brubacher's captain
america run where he positioned
the the dichotomy between captain
america and bucky okay that like
captain america was the dude who flew
the flag and could never do anything
anywhere outside the law but bucky was
an assassin like bucky was the dude you
said mohan enemy lions to shoot and
snipe [ __ ] from
from afar right and so the idea that
adam was the prototypical superhero but
duncan was the one who got it done the
dirty work the dirty work he was the
dangerous guy
and he comes across father fatherly and
very pat
patron like patriarchal
killer but he's like i
that notion that mark wrote into the
script
the most dangerous man in eternia really
kind of like
refocused the character for the rest of
the run like we play
duncan as old bruce wayne yeah
he's old batman once he like you know
he's not wearing the same outfit anymore
but he's still got the skills
yeah and so the original conceit was he
was you know kind of like a monk like he
had
done his his work he had been exiled
from from the palace and from
his position as a man of arms and he was
then on the hinterlands of attorney like
training the next generation of people
who would eventually fight to defend the
light and there were two kids there were
two
that he had he's a boy not he had like
i've got children but kids that he was
training
right all of this what you're seeing
right now the colton stuff
came later on because and that was
predicated on
the script for episode two once we had
the colt in episode two
then we were like oh well let's string
them over into this and that's what
duncan is
he's going to get the idea was he was
always
like originally he was training these
kids
but he was also taking care of orco
right because in the cartoons
he was always like orco so we felt like
in
as they grow up like he actually had to
be the guy who took they were both
banished from the palace because king
randor doesn't
didn't know the secret so duncan got
banished and so does orco
so this was always meant to be the
duncan orgo
uh episode and also like we're on our
way two sets up the fellowship of who's
going on the journey to find the two
halves of the power sword
and in order to put that sword together
obviously they're going to need
like the the guy who if anybody could
reforge this sort of power
it's man at arms it's duncan so that
story
originally was duncan's a monken
monken donuts and he is training the
kids for
the coming battles in the coming war
he's no longer part of the
the royal court or anything like that
but he still has all the skills and the
idea
was that when tila and him interact
again
she's there was another flashback in the
script
right to when young tila would train
with young adam
and how duncan was the one behind both
of them and and just sort of setting up
that dichotomy
and her love for her you know
adopted father ultimately and her love
for adam and how those two things kind
of went at odds with each other
and you know and then but this this
opening actually does a lot of that work
more efficiently and to to its its
virtue with a lot more action
that's true that was the one thing like
as you sit around in a writer's room
you're like okay this is the in this
episode
there's a lot of talking you've got a
bunch of writers in a room
none of them are talking about action
they're all talking about what they say
to each other and [ __ ] which is
mind-bending because this cartoon it was
all about
supposed to be all about action back in
the day so you're right
it's in the old opening that like the
only action was he was training the kids
yeah to fight and then tila takes him
down yeah
you know but it was very it was all
about character it was all deep into
into their rift and their problems which
remains
like it just got pulled into like
another version of the scene and the
idea
here of like all right let's keep the
threat of
these cats alive you know the
snake mountaineers the people who are
all about motherboards and stuff like
that
so that it didn't feel like a one-off
and we never go back and also we weave
them throughout and they become
increasingly more important as we get to
the end of the story you'll see
yeah but this is this is much more old
batman
and i think you established that much
firmer here than it was in the original
draft so yeah nice job
it is a it's a it's a real [ __ ] cheat
though to have her be like uh
you fight well for an old man he's like
being an old man
is something i know all about it's like
you ca even without his [ __ ]
helmet you can tell it's duncan and
stuff but that's that you get to cheat
like that in cartoons
the the orco scene pretty much
remain untouched yeah no it's pretty
much as
written it's really sweet you know
because now we bring orko in
like what what had happened to all of
our characters from eternia
especially the ones we had been with you
know the entire run of the show
and so to be able to reintroduce them
and like where are they now and what has
happened to them and the idea that
magic in eternia is on the wane and so
would orco
as one of the more magical characters in
eternia and if the sorceress is also
fading
then so would so would be orco and orco
the conversation we had in the writers
room about orca was like
he's the he's the controversial
character
of the old show because some people
absolutely love him particularly
when they were younger kids because he
was funny for kids
but you know people my age watching it
back then like when you were like
towards your teens or early teens orco
was like this show would be so good if
they didn't have to deal with this
[ __ ] orco character
you know what i'm saying like he always
makes jokes and he's bad at
magic and he's always putting him in
jams like so
there was a feeling you know we looked
on the internet that some people are
like [ __ ] orco
so we were like all right how do we make
everybody want orco
as a tattoo how do you make orco
so [ __ ] amazing that people are like
work is my favorite character in all of
masters in the universe i like them
better than [ __ ] he-man
that was a challenge and we figured like
the first step of that
is this yeah just break them keep pathos
yeah he's he's no longer the [ __ ]
little clown and [ __ ] like that he's
older wiser he's he's us
yeah he's a middle-aged man
who realized that they don't have the
power they used to have when they were
younger it's all gone
um i saw a picture of somebody
cosplaying orco online
as a tall person and i was like we could
have done that
never occurred to me to grow him up you
know to make him tall like he was just a
little kid or something like that he
still remains the same size
no i mean i sort of liked the the
challenge of at least for me beginning
this story the orco story of doing for
orko
what star wars never did for the ewoks
which was
they appear as a thing that me as a
person just old enough to remember how
awesome it was before he walks
i think any watch he's like why why
couldn't these just be wookies wookies
would have been better
and so it's like this redemption story
for the character that feels too
childish for the world that he's in
yes and and winds up being
quite the grown-up indeed um this you
did exceptional work on roboto played by
the great j
uh justin long uh this is his debut uh
in the cartoon in the series um
the relationship that they have um is
kind of based on the fact
mark wrote it that since duncan built
roboto roboto
would essentially be duncan so that
[ __ ] like what later on
comes to play is when roboto is kind of
laying out why he should go
on the journey because like if duncan
knows how to forge the sword of power
then so does roboto and stuff
and like there's a really nice moment
where he talks about
you know um you know duncan goes and
since you're me i know i wouldn't have
taken no for an answer either it was
such an old man line to write
yeah only could come from a middle-aged
man and it's beautiful and it works so
goddamn well you know and also the idea
that
duncan hits heartbreak right here like
listen listen to him [ __ ] like the
the
just the please tila like griffin newman
his his performance here is just give
him an emmy
like he breaks your heart with him he's
a little kid who's like i love when he
goes like
i won't mess up like the old times like
oh
oh it's good stuff yeah but you know the
idea that duncan had created
roboto as the surrogate son that he
never had
right to fill the void that tila left
when she
refused to associate with him at all
like he needs a child
he needs somebody to care to protect
yeah otherwise what's all he's fighting
for
what's all what's all the war about why
do we need all these arms if you're not
going to be the man
yeah he don't want to do no war no more
no but he's going to get sucked back
into it
that line still maintains two where he's
like my world saving days are behind me
and his delivery is [ __ ] pitch
perfect liam cunningham like we were
talking about when we started casting
we're like
what if we got like sir davos it's and
he had just done
rick and morty where he played that's my
favorite little gag right there is the
upside down fruit bowl helmet and he's
been storing his fruit in his own
um but you know we were like uh god what
was i just saying
getting liam yes he had just done rick
and morty where he was a sexed up dragon
so they i was like he just did a cartoon
he did rick and morty
and uh they were like uh what colette
who was our
uh casting director and she cast you
know she's the one that does all the
voice direction and stuff
um she was like you mean the cartoon
dragon that wants to have sex i was like
yeah he'll still be a very serious voice
and uh he was he's so he gives it such
gravity there's another moment right
there
where somebody wants to say something
you know what happened in episode one uh
there's a moment i believe in episode
two and it happens here where you know
it's like tila
i have to tell you something and usually
it's evil and going oh no
like we gotta go because we're gonna
pull that taffy as
long as we can kids but anybody you know
who's ever seen i don't know
television will understand that we're
setting up for something to happen
that is a little heartbreaking moment in
the episode when he
they shake hands she won't hug him she
just shakes his hand
but it pays off later on crystal c
and the references in this scene come
from the old show
they do very much and i went back to
find that episode
because i remember wondering because i
wanted i wanted evelyn to take her hat
off yes
did they do it in the episode they did
and that's how i knew she had white hair
that's crazy i always thought like i was
such a nice touch i was just like
that's cool i wonder why she never did
that before oh my god i don't even
remember that so she took her hat off
and [ __ ]
yeah and so you're like i'm doing it
[ __ ] it i know she's got white hair
let's do it and give her the
long how she squeezes that much hair up
under that little
believe me i've been looking at that for
two years going like that's a cheat
it's magic yes it truly is um and here
she's got some wonderful [ __ ]
dialogue they're back and forth here is
and then
and also in the woods in the jungle
scene as they're coming through
where they're kind of needling each
other about their
you know others like she's giving her
[ __ ] about like you were all in the
skeletor she's like you're all in a
he-man and stuff
um really nice stuff yeah i mean it's
it it doesn't pass the bechdel test yeah
uh in that
we have two women on screen talking
about their boyfriends yeah but
it actually does kind of fuse them
together it makes them understand who
the other is
by their unwillingness to leave that old
person behind
you know and it is a nice and god
listening to
friggin you know buffy and cersei just
kind of bat that stuff back and forth
oh geez i know there's that aspect as
you watch the show you're like oh my god
those voices i've been hearing
my whole life and other things like how
neat um
tiffany gets to do some nice work in the
scene griffin of course
like [ __ ] wipes everybody off the
screen the moment the pathos the pathos
and
broken orco kicks in and stuff but i
always love that line that you wrote
where she's like um
like he goes it's days like this you
don't think you're gonna remember and
she's like what
look at this why would i not remember
that it's a crystal freaking scene
exactly um this of course as we were
plotting out
um the series in the writers room uh we
knew
of course merman would come to play and
our version of
merman is played by the great kevin
conroy so earlier on the episode
we got mark hamill and kevin comroy the
joker and batman
doing two different other characters in
a scene acting opposite one another
um here the idea was to play merman
as shakespearean uh
broken befouled so uh
as you'll see uh when kevin comes up
he gives a very like almost centurion
delivery
of you know and and there's a line
that like always like it made it all the
way to the end where he
references uh without skeletors
raging ego which like mark wrote which i
was like
it's so funny like i would never when i
think of skeletor all the things i think
of him i would never be like he's so
egotistical but he's absolutely right
the thing that upended all of his
[ __ ] schemes was he was
egotistical so when he brought it up in
the script i was like that's pretty
[ __ ] dope
um the boys at powerhouse did you write
he has a bad iron
i don't think i did so i think they were
just like let's just age and i think all
the scars on them is all a thing that
they just brought to the table they were
like let's just man them up i remember
teddy uh be a celery over at netflix was
like kill him
and i was like not gonna kill merman
like [ __ ] he's like you already
killed boss man kill him kill merman i
was like
no we'll need him we'll need him again
man so
so merman lives if his name is
alligative we kill him
that was like at a certain point teddy
got very excited by the amount of
characters we were killing
because that's what teddy really wanted
he's like i want a master's universe
with stakes
where like you if you die you [ __ ]
die and somebody could get hurt and
stuff like that so
anytime we were like can we do this he
was like yes
do it more crutch all you want we'll
make more but i do feel good about
merman living i i let him live i was
like spare
spare merman please uh if you look real
closely he shoots
um because that was in the script i
believe he shoots his [ __ ] line
straight through orco
because you know orco who knows what's
going on between
cloak and hat and stuff um they tried to
capture it with the animation i love
this look this looks so [ __ ] like
dope i'm coming at him swiping and [ __ ]
and he's got the strength man this is
what like you know on the internet i
spent a lot of time on youtube and they
always have like
this one versus this one this one
there's this one fights when this [ __ ]
drops there's gonna be so many like
man at arms versus merman orc over
scarecrow
[ __ ] so forth and so on like all the
mini battles i think we're gonna see
lots of like you know man at arms versus
batman i mean the dude flies in with
rocket launchers on his shoulders and
awesome
grappling stuff like he's a badass boys
took that very seriously when we were
like we're playing them like old batman
they're like done and done
and then when you start seeing the
animatics like oh my god they went back
to the
dc stuff and they were like we're just
gonna kind of a batman style and why did
they do it this here's a moment i always
wondered and this is uh
like i threw in a line about her she you
know she
there's a lot of fish fish [ __ ] thrown
his way
is that like fishes like you know what
i'm
just telling you yeah like after when i
saw the episode i was like
you know she's awfully racist about fish
i don't know if this
plays but like when you're a different
if you're a bad guy and you're a
different species
in science fiction and somebody's like
you fish yeah can you be like you fish
face [ __ ] or is that like hey man that's
like
[ __ ] the equivalent of like making
fun of a native american or something
like that i mean i think the loophole is
she's a bad guy [ __ ] a good person
you hear that bad guys bad guys i can do
bad guy things
got things indeed and don't have to have
empathy there is a there's an expression
on mirror man's face though like where
you could see he's kind of
we should throw one more line in one
because he jumps into the ocean
he says some [ __ ] here some real deep
crimson [ __ ] then he jumps in
and then pops up for his ps line
and neither do i like he dove in and he
was like well i got one more thing to
say he pops up and
neither do i but we should have to pop
up one more time to be like
and you're real [ __ ] vicious go
swimming away
maybe that's what season two will be
about every yeah just merman just
showing up every 25 feet with a new
thing to add
it's like yes pops up season two is
merman
colon race war because he basically
takes on
all the people on land we're tired of
being called fish we're not even fish
see what i look forward to is the
internet doing what the internet does
and dubbing in new lines for merman
whenever he pops out of there
that could be a meme man him pops back
up to add one more phone by the way
that's your ps every argument that
moment was paid off
where you know a man at arms goes to
shake tila's hand but instead of course
she embraces her
yeah the the father storyline stuff is
really [ __ ] sweet between them and
the show
this is a dope [ __ ] scene and i
remember like this is where the
powerhouse kids are so much better than
us as writers because it was just like
she's got the havoc staff
head and it was like there's a big
crystal gate
yeah it's like she puts it into the door
in the door it's like how about we give
him a [ __ ] skeleton
i was so dope when i saw the first
animatic i was like holy [ __ ]
it makes sense they're putting the head
on a body
and [ __ ] so it was kind of dope and then
we start heading into
hell itself indeed what if anything
missing from the first draft do you
remember or feel like i could have
played that could stay
you know not too much man i think that
that
the joy of animation and this is like
the second time i've got to poke in it
but the first time that i've actually
been as involved in it um
it's just watching it get better and
different and realizing the things that
you didn't really need
and the guys at powerhouse were
incredibly smart you were incredibly
smart about
yeah no we're we we can we can flay this
part off
this is fat that more [ __ ] fish talk
more
more efficient maybe we can just fillet
a bit we can take the bones out here
for those who are offended by the
comment filet or other fish viewers
we apologize for all our aquatic uh
americans
[Laughter]
but no i mean it it everything distills
down and the the wonder of iteration is
that it gets better and better and
better the hope is that it doesn't get
worse
but when it's working when the team is
working as well as this team is working
everything is what it should be and
nothing that that got cut from the first
or second or third drafts
are things that i'm like you know what
that was better than
all right you guys [ __ ] it up
it was a really nice kind of moment that
the powerhouse boy stretched out it's in
the script where she has to go back for
the head of the havoc staff because
it'll come into play
later on but they turned it into a beat
where she's
the what you're hopefully seeing is
the more distance she has from skeletor
the more she's realizing that she was in
an incredibly abusive relationship so
you know you see this thing where she's
ready to walk away the havoc staff
served its purpose it opens the gate to
subternia but she can't she stops she
can't
leave it because she's still even though
she hates him
she still has something for skeletor in
her heart and they
they they pulled that taffy out of it
they do it's the you know you're you're
burning all of the stuff
from that old boyfriend or girlfriend
but you you hold on that last
thing that last ticket stub that last
that ticket to house
you're like maybe i do want that after
all maybe i don't want to forget all
of it what if he comes back he's gonna
want it my brother's back it's gonna be
trouble
we uh we played subternia has always
existed and none of this stuff
you know was created by me or him or
anybody who's written on the show
it's all from motu lore uh subternia
existed and pre-ternia existed preternia
was meant to be prehistoric
um eternia so they can go back and tell
old stories of hero
and stuff like that but uh for our
purposes
um subternia in in our iteration of
masters of the universe
revelation is hell and uh
pre-ternia is essentially our version
of heaven as you'll come to see when we
get to episode five or by the tail end
of episode four
actually so mark brought us into hell
man i did that was i
i took that upon as a as a sacred quest
as a noble journey we're on the highway
to hell boys and girls it's [ __ ]
metal
hell yeah it's goddamn metal um as a guy
who stood next to you
for years and was like man he's a good
[ __ ] writer
uh i was happy to have that proved out
well thank you wonderful episode
um as i said before each one of these
episodes gets
[ __ ] better so like this i feel is a
superior episode to episode one
um it's just [ __ ] duncan comes alive
man and this is the duncan like you've
always loved and always
felt in your heart who he was you know
and and boyle boy you played that track
insanely well yeah i mean every episode
like the or we get to we get to where we
get to with orco because of the strong
work that was laid
in episode three every writer that
follows the one before
reads their script and then builds on it
so
mark set the tone for our broken orco
and there's some stuff in episodes four
and five that's just
gobsmackingly great yeah you know it is
all once again it's all set up with
what's kind of gone before orco only
gets to be as great as he gets to be
because in this episode
you made him so [ __ ] pathetic
look at that sad sad old man yeah it's
like [ __ ] if
even if you hated orko your whole life
after that scene where he's like please
tila
i need more life
i'm gonna cut this [ __ ] a break oh
[ __ ] i guess his clowning is over
oh it is way to see where he goes indeed
from little orcos
big trees grow as the saying goes
as the attorney in favor of this yes uh
there it is kids
that was episode three of masters of the
universe uh revelation where can they
get your shirt
um the this shirt and the internet um
the shirts that i that i uh as part of
the mark bernard universe i have to sell
embattledclothing.com um and you can uh
you know be humble but let [ __ ]
know don't forget to watch us
mostly every weekend on fat man beyond
ladies and gentlemen this is
this has been a little taste of that
you've never if you've never enjoyed the
magic of fat man beyonce
jump in the pool kids it's like this all
the time this is a song
this is just an aperitif it's a taste is
that how you pronounce it aperitif a
pair of teeth always said aperitif
i mean you know tomato tama but it's got
an eye in it you're right
i was just i was like it's probably a
simon i just made that decision
it's a silent doctor i was like that eye
is not more important than i
that's true i we're writers
we make up our own [ __ ] rules did you
enjoy this episode kids
that's a job so if you're an adult and
you've got a little kid and you've
watched the show
make sure you tell them like see that
man he wrote those words
you wrote those dumb beautiful blues so
some kid will be like i want to be that
guy and stuff yeah just like mark did
that
did this not just existed not just
springfully formed onto the internet no
people wrote it they made it and that's
a it's a career
if you do it well thank you for hanging
out with us here on masters of the
universe revelation
celebration and celebration of the
writers of mass of the universe of
revelation i'm kevin smith
i'm mark bernard uh we should sign off
of course with the way that e-man would
sign off uh
or co-opted you have the power oh
yeah you do this
is the cat greetings everybody and
welcome
to the aka ask kev anything
every saga has a 10 year anniversary
ladies and gentlemen and this is what
happens with jay and sam bob get old i'm
kevin smith